how's it going bros my name is Brianna
back welcome back to some work in them
as well
black kick thank you hey open hey cow
it's creeping me out
[ __ ] cows man alright I think I
chopped well and one wanna [ __ ] with me
you don't [ __ ] with mannequin arms and
one there
nah god damn it alright I'll just go
down here
welcome put my name is Brianna back
welcome back to condemned I don't
remember if I said it sometime it is
5:00 in the morning and Sarah killer
police fits all and by lesson [ __ ]
I'm not too violent I shot Thomas
speaking Thomas token hey how do you
know this number anyway yeah that's my
potential again with the instincts Kappa
it's my stefana
let's come man a man manikin the man how
you then a crowbar I think I need this
actually unfortunate thing hey what is
that there's nothing I guess Oh
what is this subway duck under that's
not how you duck silly man I know I was
like
the investigate is this all right oh
whoa whoa whoa you're not supposed to be
here not cool all right we're good we're
good
scanner sighs it's like it's her that
don't scare me around the corner what
are you doing swinging there that's
right in your [ __ ] and robbed our power
oh you [ __ ] piece of said you get
whoa don't oh that's right no battles ha
ha I do it I dare you there's a dead
bird oh I guess that's why the scanner
was telling me to go high then let's go
in here
of course not we have to go there you
[ __ ] barrel you better not be working
with them
oh that's right sorry power that's right
right in your buzz whoa how did he fall
far away
all right which one does he want number
honor all right I didn't do it I like it
I'll just kill him anyway I totally saw
that coming
piece of shits all right keV a guy that
says boogie bag Motel is that all right
sup Toby back talk to you later
I should break one of these ATMs like
get a lot of money I love the sound
track all right
servers get lonely too
yeah I guess that's right what are you
doing whoa what the hell come down Matt
what
mr. Shetty oh you don't oh come on bring
it
blockage whoa nice shot blockage nice
stopping so awesome yeah Devin don't run
away from me
how did Emma judge ass punishing that's
what you get follow trail and developer
flood Chinese food
what are you doing dead I'll be dead
can't go in there radians I don't like
this why is it this guy here I don't
want to kill him card right and job deck
punch oh nice
whoa pretty Lita this alright let's
follow the trail it's going over here
well that's a problem I guess we have to
take this way
don't [ __ ] with me what the [ __ ] was
that
I don't want to meet him look where's
sledge II I saw you sledge II I saw I
saw it sledge hammer it's fine Saji
whatever let's follow this ring hey
don't touch me back repairs on my team
that's right
BAM Oh calm down everyone calm down
oh yeah you know it harsh nipples hurt
Erica got [ __ ] hot
step it ass off crow he knows what he's
doing
alright let's queue follow the trail I
guess it goes here yeah Wow
checkpoint good mean that [ __ ]
I guess you gotta take the elevator
somehow bad [ __ ] my bare feet back
what are you female wait wait okay fire
is required all right we need ax e speak
axe nice somewhere I'm sure we'll find
it here somewhere
keep out haha I'll go anyway where's the
axe did I walk in cycle Oh
maybe down here oh my god job that hard
danger asbestos awesome best I'm in no
sense I don't know why I said that
that's okay be back I am Scout poppy
baby did he call me poppy
no no I'm sorry it's cuz of me was it
that Oh hold me baby can't do it I'm
sorry
I go up here I have a holiday like I'm
technically holding you you know don't
[ __ ] with me in this
and this right came from no I didn't oh
no oh hell no I need that health kits
back up whoa
oh you died sorry I don't really need it
well calm down calm down everyone calm
down
ah don't chase me bro don't hate me bro
wait keep going far away so which one do
you one hey give him ah too late
[ __ ] it you'd have to have some ease
pass their people I'm sorry I guess I
can climb over here oh I have to fire x9
we'll just go back all right I'll see
you later prepare sorry can I just jump
down there we go
sup sup everyone speak Japanese or act
do you rent me any language it's cool
actually the whole thing but bring it
[ __ ]
I know all these people coming from
anyway make Nothing oh I hear you whoa
don't swear in acts these presents are
they doing fighting each other or making
love
probably hey what are you doing knock
this off hey that's right takes your
eyes alright were you fighting so
unnecessary I'll just go in here now
yeah paradise I swear I'm gonna do that
every time I'm sorry alright hey that
looks like an iPod for a second ah
err I'm sorry that will get sold after
Wyatt
oh that's taped call now what is going
on in here
I gotta follow the trail right he's
really not very cautious with this
fellow that he left after him I guess I
gotta jump over this I swear to God if
you can't pass this you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] I come on really fat man you
can't squeeze through this little video
games sometimes you don't make sure I
get all I got I ask nice why would I -
I'm sorry
I like hairy stops anyways like try how
it hey mr. J you're doing it
Carl what's going on in here whoa that's
things you gonna like the ripple TV
achievement Wow I'm so happy right now
uh all right what was the point of this
hello health care I am full hell why
would I take a health care may but yes I
know but I can't I'm too fat I'm too fat
I'm sorry
I'm too fat I can't do it why do you
keep kept yeah damn it that pest
something out what the hell
yeah elevator what the hell am I
supposed to do it makes no sense
come on I'm gonna get stopped by that
stupid [ __ ]
you took the elevator huh I'm supposed
to take a photo of something
what's the evidence all the fingerprint
ah cut I did that I nailed that [ __ ]
like I got it yeah you better
that's right yeah goddamnit
keep looking she said you must have saw
a pilot out before continuing search
power Wow
what are you doing count whoa nice
acrobatic skills man okay so I guess
I'll do that here oh cool
can we use the elevator or not power up
now that may thing oh there you are
cut all right how does the gun in here I
like going the elevator
you don't mind especially when I have an
axe everyone else like a random guy a
peer psych hey sir that's nothing just
walking around backs I'll do this
oh I don't really talk something and
it's like hey uh how's everyone doing in
here are you doing there dead bird what
I'm going with you
why am i collecting that's fine well who
did that
whoa what the [ __ ]
Wow all right my feelings in sight okay
this is the right way I think I really
need help all right what's going on in
here that little [ __ ] blocked
everywhere oh [ __ ] you
oh you better take dear Redmayne you let
off [ __ ] oh don't sweat it back up
where are ya hey come here that's right
Oh
who shot me hi it's when you shoot me
man
all right in your [ __ ] [ __ ] no no no
don't you know I swear to god don't do
any I'm innocent innocent watch what's
that girl doing that it's a bird girl
you're dead no [ __ ] Sherlock
all right let's kind of go a road day
and I'll see you next episode hopefully
I'll learn to use the combats a bit
better that's family [ __ ] caramel
activate
[Music]
being somewhere huh